what would be some of the reasons that
the government would not tell the
citizens of something extraordinary
occurring other than wanting the
technology so that they can outpace
China or Russia for instance one reason
would be panic but what would be some
other reasons
yeah I mean Panic is a broad term but it
could be there's just sort of the
destabilization of a society that might
occur if people were really freaked out
about it I mean I think that protecting
technology is the number one
protecting data that we don't want our
adversaries to have
but number two yeah could be the impact
on Society number three could be
concerns about
um
you know uh going after people who have
you know trying to convict people or or
going after people who have been
involved with keeping the secret over so
many years trying to
take them to court or whatever you know
kind of a vendetta going on
um
a lot of the anger that we've we haven't
been told sooner
uh you know it's a it's loaded
um and I you know I think if something
like this does come out it would
wouldn't be a bad idea to have some kind
of amnesty for those
from the Past who were doing what they
thought they needed to do and were told
to do
um but then you know there's questions
of of crimes that may have been
committed of people who are harmed or
even killed to keep them quiet I mean
you know it opens up such a can of worms
and maybe there's a way for something to
come out in which
the past is not
dragged along with it which I personally
think would make a lot more sense and be
cleaner and for us to just focus on the
present what we know now
and not get bogged down and digging
through the past and all the misdeeds
that occurred for all kinds of
complicated reasons
uh and I don't know some people might
not like me saying that but I don't
think it's productive personally
um
and then there you know there could be
other reasons I mean maybe the
explanations that our government is
withholding for us are much
scarier than we might think or
there's an acknowledgment that has to be
made of a lack of power that we might
have or our military might have a lack
of ability to control this phenomenon to
keep people safe
that of course was connected to what
you're saying about panic but
you know there I it's a it's um the
implications that it might have
for the public can be complicated and I
mean the fact that it's it's a gradual
unfoldment probably makes a lot of sense
shock people you don't want to disrupt
the structures that we have in society
that you know
could be impacted by this
um and some people believe Kurt that
it really isn't going to be a big deal
for if this announcement were made some
people believe and if you know people
have pie levels that
for a long time that it really won't be
a big deal and that most people just
won't be that concerned about it I mean
we have to remember that the
raising their kids and the question for
them would be well yeah that's kind of
interesting but it doesn't affect my
life
and if it's not anything that I have to
worry about or be scared of for me and
my family
then I I don't really care that much and
I'm just gonna go about my life you know
it's not necessarily going to affect
everyone
some people don't have a curiosity about
stuff either they're just focused on
their daily lives and they're struggling
to survive every day
so